هل ستستقيل الحكومة اللبنانية
أم سيستقيل وزير إعلامها جورج قرداحي من تلقاء نفسه؟
هل سترضخ الحكومة اللبنانية للضغوطات الخليجية
خوفاً من إغلاق حنفية الدعم؟
هل سيركع لبنان ويخضع لإرادة أمراء النفط؟
وهل كلمة الحق في وجه سلطان جائر جريمة سياسية.
قالها جورج قرداحي وبكل حزم
يطالبني بعضهم بالاستقالة، أقول لهم
أنا جزء من حكومة متكاملة،
ولست لاهثاً خلف سلطة أو منصب سياسي
ولا يجوز أن نظل في لبنان تحت عرضة الابتزاز
لا من دول ولا من سفراء ولا من افراد
ألسنا دولة ذات سيادة؟
وهنا يأتي الرد من الحكومة اللبنانية قائلةً
إن لم يتنحى جورج قرداحي قد تستقيل الحكومة اللبنانية
كاملة لأجل مصلحة لبنان.
فهل ستضحي الحكومة اللبنانية
بنفسها فعلاً من أجل إرضاء الخليج؟